let's see if we can learn a thing or two
about even
even functions and odd functions so even
functions and on the right hand side
over here we'll talk about odd functions
and if we have time we'll talk about
functions that are neither even nor odd
so before i go into kind of a formal
definition of even functions i just want
to show you what they look like visually
because i think that's probably the
easiest way to recognize them and then
it'll also make a little bit more sense
when we talk about the formal definition
of an even function
so let me draw some coordinate axes here
x-axis
and then
let me see if i can draw that a little
bit straighter
this right over here is my y axis so i
could say y is equal to f of x
axis just like that and then let me draw
the graph of
f of x
f of x is equal to x squared or y is
equal to x squared either one so let me
draw it in the first quadrant it looks
like this
and then in the
second quadrant it looks
like this it looks like let me try to
draw it
so it's
symmetric pretty good job
the f of x is equal to x squared is an
even function and the way that you
recognize it is because it has the
symmetry around the y axis if you take
if you take what's going on on the
right-hand side to the right of the
y-axis and you just reflect it over the
y-axis you get the other side of the
function and that's what tells you it is
an even function and i want to show you
one interesting property here you take
any x value let's say you take a
positive x value let's say you take the
value x is equal to 2.
if you find f of 2 that's going to be 4
that's going to be 4 for this particular
function for x f of x is equal to x
squared 2 squared is equal to 4.
and if you took the negative version of
2. so if you took negative 2
if you took negative 2 and you evaluated
the function there you're also you are
also going to get 4. and this hopefully
or maybe makes complete sense to you
you're like well sal obviously if i just
reflect this function over the y-axis
that's going to be the case whatever
function value i get at the positive
value of a number i'm going to get the
same function value at the negative
value and this is what kind of leads us
to the formal definition if a function
is even
i could say a function is even if and
only if so it's even and don't get
confused between the the term even
function and the term even number
they're completely different uh kind of
ideas so there's there's not at least an
obvious connection that i know of
between even function and even numbers
or odd functions and odd numbers so
you're an even function
if and only if
f of
f of x is equal to f of negative x
and the reason why i didn't introduce
this from the beginning because this is
really the definition of an even
function is when you look at this you're
like hey what does this mean f of x is
equal to f of negative x and all it does
mean is this it means that if i were to
take f of 2 f of 2 is 4 so let me show
you with a particular case f of 2 is
equal to f of negative 2
f of negative 2. in this particular case
for f of x is equal to x squared they
are both
they are both equal to 4. so really it's
just this is just another way of saying
that the function can be reflected or
the left side of the function is the
reflection of the right side of the
function across
across the vertical axis across the y
axis now just to make sure we have a
decent understanding here let me draw a
few more even functions
and i'm going to draw some fairly wacky
things just so that you really kind of
learn to visually recognize them so a
function
a function like
let's say a function that like this
a function like this and maybe it jumps
up to here it does something like
maybe it does something like that and
then on this side it does the same thing
it's the reflection so it jumps up here
then it goes like this and then it goes
like this i'm trying to draw it so it's
they're the mirror image of each other
this is an even function you take what's
going on on the right hand side of this
function and you literally just reflect
it over the y-axis and you get the
left-hand side of the function and you
can see that even this holds if i take
some value let's say that this let's say
that this value right here is i don't
know three and let's say that f of three
over here is so f of three is equal to i
don't know let's say that that is five
so this is five we see that f of
negative three
so we see that f of negative three is
also going to be equal to five and
that's what our definition of an even
function told us i can draw i can let me
just draw one more to really make sure
i'll do the axis in that same green
color
let me do one more
like this
and
you could have maybe some type of
trigonometric looking function that
looks like this
that looks like that
and it keeps going in either direction
so something like this would also be
even so all of these are even functions
now you are probably thinking well what
is an odd function
and let me draw an odd function for you
so let me draw the axes once again
x axis
y axis or the f of x axis
and to show you an odd function i'll
give you a particular odd function maybe
the most famous of the odd functions
this is probably the most famous of the
even functions
and it is f of x although there are
probably other contenders for most
famous odd function f of x is equal to x
to the third power and it looks like you
might have seen the graph of it
if you haven't you could graph it by
trying some points it looks like that
and the way to visually recognize an odd
function
is you look at what's going on on the to
the right of the y-axis once again this
y-axis this is the x-axis you have all
of this business to the right of the
y-axis if you reflect it over the y-axis
you would get something like this
you would get something like this and if
the left side of this graph looked like
this then we would be dealing with an
even function clearly it doesn't
to make this an odd function we reflect
it once over the y-axis and then reflect
it over the x-axis or another way to
think about it reflect it once over the
y-axis and then make it negative either
way it'll get you there or you could
even reflect it over the x-axis and then
the y-axis so you're kind of doing two
reflections and so clearly if you take
this up here and then you reflect it
over the x-axis you get these values
you get this part of the graph right
over here
and if you try to do it with a
particular point
and i'm doing this to kind of a hint at
what the definition the formal
definition of an odd function is going
to be
let's try a point
let's try two again if you have the
point two f of two is eight
so f of two
is equal to eight now what happens if we
take negative two
if we take negative two f of negative 2
f of negative negative to the third
power that's just going to be negative
8.
so f of negative 2 is equal to negative
8. and in general if we take let me just
write it over here f of 2 so we're just
doing one particular example from this
from this particular function
we have f of two
is equal to
not f of negative two eight does not
equal negative eight eight is equal to
the negative of negative 8 because
that's positive 8. so f of 2 is equal to
the negative of f of negative 2
f of negative 2. we figured out just
want to make it clear we figured out f
of 2 is 8. 2 to the 3rd power is 8. we
know that f of negative two is negative
eight negative two to the third power is
negative eight so you have the negative
of negative eight negatives cancel out
and it works out so in general you have
an odd function so here's here's the
definition you are dealing with an odd
function
if and only if
f of x
for all the x's that are defined on that
function or for for which that function
is defined
if f of x is equal to the negative of f
of negative x or you'll sometimes see it
the other way if you multiply both sides
of this
really equation by negative 1 you would
get
negative f of x
is equal to f of negative x and
sometimes you'll see it where it's
swapped around where they'll say f of
negative x
is equal to
is equal to
f
is equal to let me write that be careful
is equal to negative
negative f of x i just swapped these two
sides
and so let me just draw you some more
odd functions
some more odd functions so i'll do these
visually
so let me draw that a little bit cleaner
so
if you have a
maybe it looks something maybe the
function does something
wacky
maybe it does something wacky like this
on the right hand side if it was even
you would reflect it there but we want
to have an odd function so we're going
to reflect it again so the rest of the
function is going to look like this
so what i've drawn in the non-dotted
lines this right here is an odd function
and you can even look at the definition
if you take some value a
and then you take f of a which would put
you up here this right here would be f
of a if you take the negative value of
that if you took negative a here
negative a f of negative a is going to
be down here
so f of negative a f of negative a is
going to be equal is going to be the
same distance from the horizontal axis
it's not completely clear the way i drew
it just now
so it's maybe going to be like right
over here so this right over here is
going to be f of negative a which is the
same distance from the origin as f of a
it's just the negative it's not i didn't
completely draw it to scale let me draw
one more
of these odd functions i think you might
get the point actually i'll draw a very
simple odd function just to show you
that it doesn't always have to be
something crazy
so a very simple odd function
would be
y is equal to x
y is equal to x
something like this
whoops
y is equal going through the origin you
reflect what's on the right on to the
left you get that and then you reflect
it down you get all of this stuff in the
third quadrant so this is also an odd
function now i want to leave you with a
few things that are not odd functions
that sometimes might be confused to be
odd functions
so you might have something
you might have something like this
where you have a maybe you have a
parabola but it does it's not symmetric
around the y axis and your temptation
might be hey there is this symmetry for
this parabola but it's not it's not
being reflected around the y axis you
don't have a situation here where f of x
is equal to f of negative x so this is
not this is neither
neither odd nor even similarly you might
see
let's say you see a shifted
a shifted cubic function so say you have
something like this
let's say you have
x to the third plus one
so f of x is equal to x to the third
plus one so it might look something like
this
and once again you'll be tempted to call
this an odd function because it's
shifted up it is no longer an odd
function you can look at that visually
so this is f of x
is equal to x to the third plus one if
you take what's on the right hand side
and reflect it onto the left hand side
you would get something like that and
then if you were to reflect that down
you would get something like that
so this is not an odd function you're
not this this isn't the uh le the left
reflection and then the top bottom
reflection of what's going on on the
right hand side this over here actually
would be